ان هنعطافه خطيره في مسار الحرب وتصعيد من
العيار الثقيل شهدته العمليه القتاليه بين
روسيا واوكرانيا فبعد ساعات من هجمات
الروسيه المكثفه استهدفت كييف على مدى
يومين متتاليين جاء الرد من اوكرانيا
بهدمه اسفرت عن اعلى حصيله قتلى من الجنود
الروس في ضربه واحده منذ بدء هذه الحرب هي
سابقه في العدد والتصريح ايضا فلافت هذه
المره ان روسيا اعلنت عن حصيله قتل الهجوم
وعددهم 78 جنديا الهجوم الاوكراني واستهدف
مقرا لتجنيد مؤقت للقوات الروسيه في منطقه
في دنياك شرقي اوكرانيا واعلنت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه مسؤوليتها عنها الهجوم
واثاره قلقا وتسالا كيف سيكون الرد الروسي
على ما وصف بانها مجزره مكيف
وفي تفاصيل الهجومي
تم تنفيذه بصواريخ هاي مارس شديده
الانفجار وان دفاعات الجويه اسقطت اثنين
منها كما قال مصدر الامني الموال لروسيا
في دونيتك ان هجوم ماكيكا تم بعد السماح
للمجندين الروسي الجدد في معسكر التدريب
باستخدام هواتفهم واشار المصدر الى ان
الجيش الاوكراني حدد احداثيات مواقع
المجندين الروس في مكيركا بعد استخدامهم
لهواتفهم
اكتب
امريكيه الصنع مركزه تجمع الوحدات القوات
المسلحه الروسيه قرب مستوطنه في جمهوريه
المسك الشعبيه اسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه صاروخين من نوعه مارس ونتيجه
لتدمير مركز التجمع باربعه الصواريخ براس
حربي شديد انفجار قتل 63 جنديا روسيا
وسيتم تقديم كل المساعده
لاقارب واصدقاء الجنود الذين سقطوا